на 12 тисяч та річковий форум ялтинська
європейська стратегія проїхав ippon від
туриста захир їх кулі таки у їхні запити
на циpку діода криво
український мільярдер віктор пінчук
мости і про це президент України
петра порошенка за фігню тулі ти case
бралася за штуку каже і
як україна в ікони та пункти в роки
простатит зв'язку з я великий рахунок і уряд
за гали ставши першому столітті реально взявся
за складні реформи win32 ефективні на
газ для населення україни популярний за
head pulled пишемо на вашому серці
зарубець і боротьба скручування в укриття
Вкрай ефективну шиелі призначають
європейсько кулі такий однак розуміє
пусю складні ситуації біля річки упи miss a
clear я думаю ще в роті розумі ти століття
їх складних чи специфічних умовах
україна проводити реформи cr for modern
жваву та демократичні реформи та
боротьба з корупцією та реформам потрібно
датою нових імпульсів на форумі місяць
закриті до надрізу в Росії катрана думка
за хімік кулі to kill
Петро і думки про тест на донбасі про
конфлікті на сході України в них
велика завантажу для Європи по
довідковій гострій дискусії на форумі
не було менше 6 захисних політики столітті
взяв у нього частину поважається друзям
України
їхній ніокр і так вона адреса українська
влада [ __ ] лапу мід треба покликати на засіки
ще до президента порошенка
європейські кулі так і означало що
після майдану в Україні сформувалася
засланців скайс успішності та
змушувати на контроль ватої ви каноніри
форм он і 8 вдома на своїй куріння так
він їхній їй від нижніх руських і над ним і
тяжів а радянське минуло вчимо цифри
нікого на банта і стиснути його на і хоче
ух volvo ти владу не рішення замінив
Ерік вдалося ви кудись далеко на все
пункти у роки просто 5 uses
наприклад європейські кошики поки що щіток
і нас до сувал і візовий режим для
українців можуть для такого кроку його
союзу
завищується у занурення реформ завзятому про
size